auch eineinhalb Jahre nach ihrer
covet-impfung geht es Felicia Binger
immer noch sehr schlecht die junge
Schauspielerin kann kaum noch arbeiten
hat ständig Schmerzen immer wieder
allergische Reaktionen sie verträgt
viele Lebensmittel nicht mehr raus geht
sie nur noch selten
ich nehme einige Medikamente die das
ganze natürlich so ein bisschen
eindämmen aber eben auch nicht heilen
und es ist natürlich auch so dass man
mich nur dann draußen sieht oder in der
Öffentlichkeit sieht wenn es mir gut
genug dafür geht also die restlichen 20
22 Stunden des Tages sieht man mich
nicht wo ich im Bett liege und wo es mir
auch oft einfach zu schlecht geht um
schlafen zu können brennen am ganzen
Körper was von diesem Gefäßentzündungen
kommt Nerven stechen extreme Schmerzen
am Körper neurologische Schwierigkeiten
ich habe nach der Impfung eben diese
GPCR Auto Antikörper entwickelt das habe
ich im Blut nachweisen lassen Antikörper
die sich gegen ihr körpereigenes
gesundes Gewebe richten und bei Felicia
viele Symptome ausgelöst haben die sie
oft verzweifeln lassen
[Musik]
als sie sich im Mai 2021 gegen covet
impfen ließ postete sie das Video auf
Instagram sie freut sich sehr darauf die
Schauspielerin will endlich ohne Sorgen
arbeiten doch kurz danach geht es ihr
schlecht in der
lonkovic-spezialambulanz der Uniklinik
Marburg wird Felicia zum ersten Mal auch
im Hinblick auf mögliche
Impfnebenwirkungen untersucht mir hat
noch nie jemand so zugehört
und es so ernst genommen wie jetzt ist
die große Erleichterung für mutmaßlich
Co wird impfgeschädigte gibt es in
Marburg eine der wenigen
Spezialambulanzen Professor Bernhard
Schiefer leitet die Station der
Uniklinik dem Kardiologen ist es wichtig
herauszufinden warum manche Personen die
Kurve Impfung nicht vertragen und wie
sie zu behandeln sind
wir sehen keinen Unterschied des
Auftretens nach der ersten nach der
zweiten Nacht der dritten Impfung was
wir allerdings immer wieder sehen ist
das ein bestimmter Typus an an Patient
anscheinend eine besonders empfänglich
ist das sind die schlanken jungen sehr
sehr sportlichen Frauen was wir auch
sehen ist das eine hohe Assoziation
besteht zu
chronischen chronischen entzündlichen
Darmerkrankungen Rheuma und auch
Lungenerkrankungen und eine hohe
Inzidenz von
Symptomen im neurologischen und im
gefäßbereich auch Leo hat einen Termin
in Marburg der junge Mann aus Frankfurt
hatte sich mit dem KO wird Virus
infiziert als es noch keine Impfung gab
und daraufhin eine Herzmuskelentzündung
entwickelt nachdem es ihm besser ging
und die Impfungen auf den Markt waren
ließ er sich dreimal impfen und fingen
sich kurz später noch mal das Virus ein
und das war dann eben also so schlimm
wurde und Vermutung war dann eben auch
hier bei meinem ersten Termin vor drei
Monaten dass das zusammenspielte dass
ich angeschlagen war durch die Impfung
das hat schon ordentlich das hat aufs
Herz geschlagen da war wieder eine
leichte Reaktion und dann eben kam da
noch mal Corona drauf ob jetzt die
Impfung alleine die schweren
Wirkungen hervorgerufen hätte oder
Corona alleine das jetzt natürlich
schwer zu sagen der 22-Jährige muss
weiter blutdrucksenkende Medikamente
nehmen gesund ist der längst nicht
wenn ich spät zur Uni bin dann renne ich
für 30 Sekunden und sitzt dann 20
Minuten eine Vorlesung hätte ich gerade
mache und beendet extrem starker
pulsieren den ganzen Körper spürt ähm
super anstrengend und ich wach nachts
regelmäßig auf oder ich kann zehn
Stunden schlafen 8 Stunden 12 Stunden
ich habe alles durchprobiert und war tot
müde auf nach dem vierten Wecker und
muss rausgeworfen werden und von meiner
Freundin oder wenn ich wirklich ein juni
muss damit hatte ich früher nie ein
Problem was ist in seinem Körper los in
der Uniklinik Marburg gibt es eine
eigene Forschungsabteilung um das
herauszufinden große internationale
Studien fehlen bislang warum lösen das
Corona-Virus und die Impfung dagegen
manchmal Folgeerkrankungen aus dr Sophie
isoliert im Blut der Patienten tausende
Proteine
und wir wollen jetzt sehen welche sind
verändert signifikant verändert
imflammatorische Prozesse spielen da
eine Rolle das wissen wir
also Entzündungen hier wird das Blut von
kovit infizierten und geimpften
untersucht die Folgeerkrankungen hatten
beide haben ähnliche Symptome und das
spiegelt sich auch in der Anzahl
bestimmter Proteine wieder die DR Sophie
aus ihrem Blut isoliert
auf dem Bildschirm sieht man links Kurve
infizierte und geimpfte die keine
Symptome entwickelt haben in der Mitte
Seuche mit starken Symptomen
diese unterscheiden sich ihre
signifikant das sieht man gerade alles
was rot ist sind Proteine die häufiger
vorkommen bei Menschen mit
Nebenwirkungen
wir wollen wissen welche Proteine
Entzündungen hervorrufen um diese
Proteine beeinflussen zu können zum
Positiven das ist unsere Intention
zum Beispiel mit bestimmten Medikamenten
die Warteliste ist lang
Patienten kommen aus dem gesamten
Bundesgebiet und dem Ausland nach
Marburg rund 9 Monate müssen Sie auf
einen Termin warten
wir können diesen ganzen Ansturm gar
nicht mehr alleine managen wenn sie über
6000 Patienten auf der Warteliste haben
können sie nicht mehr selektieren wem
ist es wir braucht dringender unsere
Hilfe und wer braucht sie weniger
dringend
Felicia Binger haben die Medikamente
bislang nicht richtig geholfen sagt sie
deswegen hat sie sich vor einiger Zeit
für eine Blutreinigung im Deutschen
hemapheresezentrum in Köln entschieden
hier sollen die zerstörerischen
Antikörper die sie nach der Impfung
entwickelt hat aus ihrem Blut gefiltert
werden
ich habe mich für die immunazorption
entschieden weil ich nach der Impfung
positive Autoantikörper entwickelt habe
und das im Moment die einzige Behandlung
ist die zu Verfügung steht der stand
gerade ist dass ich die Kosten selber
tragen muss die Krankenkasse hat es
abgelehnt obwohl es die einzige
Behandlung ist die zur Verfügung steht
und ich versuche jetzt gerade über einen
Anwalt die Kosten zurückzubekommen
Felicia Binger fühlt sich im Stich
gelassen fünf Behandlungen sind
insgesamt vorgesehen jede kostet rund
2500 €
erfreulicherweise würden aber immer mehr
Krankenkassen die Blutreinigung bezahlen
sagt Dr Beate Jäger
die Internistin behandelt in Mülheim an
der Ruhr lonkovic-patienten und
mutmaßlich impfgeschädigte
für beide bietet sie die sogenannte help
affärese an eine Blutreinigung basierend
auf ein anti-thrombosemittel der
Handlungsbedarf sehr riesig
ich habe hier Kinder behandelt die
konnten nicht mehr den Kopf heben die
konnten nicht sprechen ich habe gestern
die Mutter eines Mädchens gesehen die
seit acht Monaten die Decke anstarrt und
gefüttert werden muss vorher völlig
gesund war nach Impfung
dann habe ich eine vorgestern eine junge
Stewardess gesehen die mir unter Tränen
gesagt hat dass sie ihrem sechsjährigen
Kind nicht mehr bei den Schularbeiten
helfen kann weil sie sich mental dazu
nicht mehr in der Lage fühlt und die
vorher ein ganzes Team geleitet hat
Menschen die völlig aus dem Leben
gerissen worden sind das ist ein Patient
der im zeitlichen Zusammenhang mit einer
Impfung eine Lähmung an
Armen und Beinen entwickelt hat dieser
Mann hat massiv viel Gewicht verloren er
kann sich nur mit einem Rollator
fortbewegen das ist ein Innenleben bei
ihm sind massive Gerinnsel vorhanden die
da nicht hingehören bei einem gesunden
und bei ihm in Folge eines Impfschadens
das ist ein junger Mann der auch sehr
viel Gewicht verloren hat nach Impfung
und seine Haut entsprechend weit
abziehen kann und auch über
muskelrückgang klagt und ähnliche
Strukturen hier im Blut hat
Blutgerinnsel Gefäßschäden und eine
auffällige Anhäufung von Thrombozyten
die die Bildung von Blutgerinnsel weiter
fördern das alles als Folge der Kurve
der Erkrankung oder der CO wird Impfung
Beate Jäger arbeitet mit einem
internationalen Team zusammen um so
viele Erkenntnisse wie möglich zusammen
sie alle sind von der Blutreinigung als
Therapie für impfgeschädigte
Patienten überzeugt und würden sich mehr
Unterstützung wünschen
ich kann nicht Millionen teure Studien
machen ich habe versucht die Diagnostik
aufzustocken nachdem ich gesehen hatte
bei einzelnen Patienten
das nach Funktion ihrer Vene zum Teil
gar kein Blutfluss möglich war und wir
dann die Nadel rausgezogen haben und
haben gesehen
dass die Patienten 12 cm lange große
Blutgerinnsel an der Nadel kleben hatte
das ganz klar war da ist ein wirklich
immer nenntes gerinnungsproblem und je
länger dieser Zustand anhält desto mehr
spielen auch
autoimmunphänomene eine Rolle deshalb
finde ich bin ich auch so begeistert
dass jetzt auch Kollegen die immun als
optionsaffäre das ein anderes Verfahren
was Antikörper aus dem Blut fischt auch
einsetzen und auch erfolgreich sind weil
Sebastian Schönheit Acryl war es ein
durchblutungsproblem dass er seinen
Schlaganfall vor eineinhalb Jahren
überlebte er und seine Frau Rebecca
wissen dass er großes Glück gehabt hat
sieben Tage nach seiner kovitimpfung
bekam der 38-Jährige starke
Kopfschmerzen zum Arzt in die Klinik
seien nur gegangen weil sein Hausarzt
nicht da war und der zwei Tage später in
den Urlaub fliegen wollte
dann ging es mit Blaulicht und
Martinshorn Richtung Uniklinik ich
hielte das in dem Moment immer noch für
etwas
übertrieben also ich konnte es noch gar
nicht richtig greifen und mit den ersten
Gesprächen mit den Ärzten dass ich eine
sinusven Thrombose habe dass ich mir den
Urlaub abschminken kann weil ich dann
nach Aussage der Ärzte
höchstwahrscheinlich in einer Kiste
wieder zurückgekommen werden
ein Schlaganfall ausgelöst durch seine
Impfung mit astra-synica davon ist nicht
nur Sebastian schönert überzeugt der
vorher gern gesund war auch die Ärzte in
zwei Kliniken haben ihm bescheinigt dass
die Thrombose in seinem Kopf mit der
kobit-impfung im Zusammenhang steht
sebastian hat den im Hersteller auf
Schadensersatz und Schmerzensgeld
verklagt wegen der ungewöhnlichen
Klarheit der Ärzte mit guten Chancen
sagt sein Anwalt Joachim Caesar Prell
aus Wiesbaden er vertritt rund 600
mutmaßlich impfgeschädigte ständig wird
es mehr
wir sind ja spezialisiert darauf
zunächst in außergerichtlichen
Vergleichsverhandlungen mit den
Impfstoffherstellern eine Einigung zu
bekommen und zwar einmal eine
Einmalzahlung aber auch was für viele
sehr wichtig ist eine monatliche Rente
in angemessener Höhe wir dürfen nicht
vergessen die meisten sind nicht mehr
berufstätig können es nicht mehr sein
oder nur in sehr geringem Umfang und
haben natürlich erhebliche
Gehaltseinbußen da davon getragen der
Anwalt kritisiert dass der damalige
Gesundheitsminister Spahn den im
Herstellern Privilegien eingeräumt hat
die Klagen gegen sie erschweren würden
gibt eine Klausel wo geregelt ist dass
wenn tatsächlich die Impfstoffhersteller
Schadenersatz Schmerzensgeld irgendwas
bezahlen müssen oder Prozesskosten eben
zahlen müssen dass das dann die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland am Ende
übernehmen muss also da sage ich einfach
dazu Gewinne werden hier privatisiert
und etwaige Risiken sozialisiert
abgewälzt auf die Steuerzahler im gerade
laufenden Prozess wurde bereits
anerkannt dass Sebastian Schlaganfall
mit der Kuh wird Impfung in Zusammenhang
steht dennoch lehnt Astra Seneca zum
Beispiel einen Vergleich ab
natürlich ist mein Risiko
nutzenverhältnis definitiv schlechter
als das besagte von von Astra Senica zur
Impfung ich habe jetzt aktuell ungefähr
10.000 Euro investiert aus eigener
Tasche und der schadensersatzwert liegt
bei 30.000 Euro
Sebastian geht es bei seiner Klage um
Gerechtigkeit insgesamt fühlt auch er
sich im Stich gelassen wenn man in
dieser besonderen Situation ist in
dieser gesellschaftlichen Not und man
ein Präparat herstellt und damit auch
offensichtlich Milliarden Gewinne macht
finde ich es fair dass wenn man wenn die
Menschen das Risiko eingehen für die
Gesellschaft dass man die dann auch
auffängt bei denen bei denen auch etwas
passiert
viele mutmaßlich impfgeschädigte setzen
große Hoffnung auf den Prozess den
Sebastian schönert gerade in Köln führt
er könnte für viele die unter der
kurve-impfung Leiden wegweisend sein
leo hat von Dr Schiefer in Marburg
erfahren dass er seine Medikamente
weiter nehmen muss der 22-Jährige hofft
dass er endlich wieder gesund wird
dass ich gut durchschlafen kann dass ich
morgens dann fit bin auch gerade jetzt
das Semester wird sehr sehr hart in der
Uni dass ich da an dem Tag einigermaßen
gut starten kann und nicht mit drei
Kaffee um 10 erst langsam in die Gänge
komme und dass ich natürlich die
Hauptsache ist dass ich dann in einem
halben Jahr in drei Monaten in einem
Jahr sagen kann okay das war es jetzt du
hast jetzt drei Jahre dich mit Rum
geärgert das Medikamente nehmen müssen
passt es hoffentlich gut überstanden
keine bleiben nicht am Herzen nicht dass
das in 30 40 Jahren später im Alter
wieder kommt das ist eben die große
Gefahr das weiß er deswegen nehme ich
die Medikamente der achtet er da drauf
ohne Schmerzen in der Medikamente würde
sie ihren Alltag gar nicht mehr
bewältigen sagt Felicia Binger wenn man
von Alltag überhaupt noch reden können
auch sie hat ihn im Hersteller verklagt
und dafür viel Geld bezahlt neben den
hohen Behandlungskosten
ich wünsche mir gesund zu werden also
einfach mein altes Leben so wie es war
wieder zurückzubekommen
und ja eben dass es kein politisches
Problem mehr ist dass die Leute ernst
genommen werden und das eben jetzt auch
als Konsequenz massiv geschaut wird wen
trifft es massiv geguckt wird welche
Vorerkrankungen also da wirklich genau
hingeschaut wird wer geimpft wird
Felicia Binger konnte ihre Blutreinigung
nicht fortsetzen weil sie allergisch auf
ein notwendiges Medikament reagiert hat
dass er einfach Pech gewesen generell
wünscht sie sich mehr Studien um
mutmaßlich ins Geschädigten zu helfen